scout the job Mardon mommy mommy the
rule is simple we're trying out
something new here today if you laugh
you will lose pushing boundaries on new
content on this channel always
innovating always looking for that fresh
new take on something you laugh you lose
no one's been bold enough to try it yet
but I am let's freakin do this why is
this the funniest thing I've ever seen
hey dude I made this pretty cool meme I
wanted to show it to you that's so funny
how'd you make it well you see first I
had this really colorful background have
been this really funny cartoon of a
salamander and then this text asked for
a water cup and fill it with soda
I call it sneaky salamander oh you want
to know I make a fresh meat well let me
show you first you take an oversaturated
hallway fill it with shadow demons and
then add some text like me and the boys
are too am looking for bait I don't know
it was funny it was just 100% accurate
I shouldn't have life this month you
know it's gonna be funny if they put
this mini crying laughing emoji god damn
it you know it's fake so totally ruins
it what are the coincidences that beer
sitting perfectly for this shot three
people and he's holding this cup like
this because this is how you hold the
cup right fake us drops nuclear bomb on
Nagasaki Japan we were just about to
surrender this is a war crime you waste
the only God the only thing we are
guilty of is me I was awesome
good thing adding laugh at that one that
could have been a problem
Homer Simpson Homer Simpson Homer
Simpson Homer Simpson Homer Simpson
Homer Simpson Homer ships you believe
what comes out of this man's mouth
[Music]
babies at 3:00 a.m.
Hey look it's more Tyler memes yay all
right okay hey look it's ninja send me
your dick pics okay moving on
phat June ribs the fruity one they have
freak yeah the fruity one comb daddy's
Fang whoa whoa geez I ripped the two fat
I'd rip two fatter one we all been there
we've all been there but I thought the
lyrics were I'm gonna take my horse to
their hotel room I'm gonna ride to like
him oh my god what is the lyrics then I
need to rap genius on this I'm gonna
take my horse to the old town road this
man will defeat Tanner's oh god its
engines
oh my god
do people and I run declined this
impressive because that's a stare and
moving bed words every somewhat
experienced flame should be able to
Jesus cry I'm sorry when mom says
there's pizza rolls
but they end up being too high help it
sounds like a Star Wars TIE fighter when
he comes back James Jones no I'm not
laughing at that I know I chuckled
better than AI untuk 'old it it wasn't
that great I bet you're wondering how my
lighting setup is so good that's because
I'm using Elgato lights baby I'm proud
to have I gotta responsibly because that
I genuinely believe in their products
they all make my life easier and their
new lights is just another great example
of that I don't even have to get up to
turn on my lights you can control it
from your phone or from your desktop you
can change that brightness you can
change the colors you can change whether
you want yellow light or white light
it's a great quality product that you
can easily attach to your desk I highly
recommend checking it out
and use the link in the description to
do so that's it
keep watching the video now genuinely
offended so there's 12 fish half of them
drowned how many fish are left 6 this
this 12 fish and half of them drowned
how many fish are left
bro-bro fish don't drown
spacious kit fishing fish can no they
can they can then dry and then they can
drown we're talking about you drown all
the time ok that's a brown fish
you're welcome Internet oh yes yes it is
perfectly cut screams these are great
jay says just cut anything at perfect
timing and it's still funny oh yeah
[Laughter]
these are great why would you scream
summer truck simulator right posture
attention teeth I well that's pretty
good that's pretty good
screams are funny loud noises make me go
haha now that's a good Eddie
[Music]
caramel hire this man
what are you gonna do Marty McFly Marty
don't do it it's so beautiful it's so
much better than my friend
hey CJ I don't think this is a good idea
no no CJ oh my gosh
[Music]
you can plan segments in that game
seriously hahaha that was it for this
week's get out the death hope you guys
had a fun time and laughing smiling and
joyful day have a great week and I will
see you in your cute little face
tomorrow
[Music]
what you never played super simulator
you know it's fun right I'm not supposed
to give my opinion but give it a try and
then you can tell me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay I'll cut you a
deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]